on any other day these markets in
illegal in India's interpretation would
have been heaving with people now all
the shutters are down and police can be
seen standing in every corner many of
the residents here have instead been
doing this mothers and sisters of
students of Allah guard Muslim
University where police crackdown on
protesting students have now taken the
movement outside the campus they too are
now protesting against the new
citizenship Amendment Act a law that
allows religious minorities from
neighboring countries to apply for
Indian citizenship the legislation
specifically excludes Muslims I'm I
remain protested our party started
because of the police brutality against
students of a mu and jamia we are
housewives we are now on the streets for
the future of our children the residents
here say they have never felt this anger
before you know so this anger not just
against the citizenship Amendment Act
which which of course is there but also
against the the police brutality the the
crackdown on the internet and on
allowing people to assemble and protest
peacefully so I think that has that has
increased the scope and the width of the
issues that are being protested
regardless of your views on the
citizenship Amendment Act you should be
there protesting against this kind of
crackdown on the right to protest and
the right to criticise and the right to
freedom of speech and expression
security forces are here in large
numbers
armed with tear gas and rubber bullets
the security forces over here are saying
that these women don't have the right
permission to protest over here but the
women are saying that they have gone to
all the required authoritative ition but
that has not been forthcoming and now
it's a standoff in many parts of the
country including the capital New Delhi
the government has imposed restrictions
and public gatherings of more than four
people across the country
civilian
have come out to protest nevertheless
and have been detained while the
government is willing to review
provisions within the law they are not
willing to retract it this will likely
lead to a larger standoff well subpoena
shrestha joins us now live from New
Delhi and how the protests shaping up
for today Sabina
so today also section four 144 is still
on so no gathering of more than four
people are allowed but across the
country Internet is shut down and across
different parts of the country and in
Assam has just got restored after more
than a week and in Kashmir it's still
off like it's been more than five months
so today in in Delhi the Bhim army which
is a political group of Dulles they are
joining the protesters starting the
protest in cha mama said and they're
going down to Jantar Mantar where most
of the protests generally happen here
and they are now going to demand the
withdrawal of the good law the new
citizenship law and the resignation of
the Home Minister Amit Shah but the
probability is that they will be
arrested before they can go very far and
friday prayers about to start which
means a large gathering of people today
a but it's quite unsure how it might end
up and how the government will react and
from the people that we've talked to
like people are saying that this is
going to this has gone beyond the
universities and the protest will
continue and it's more than just just
about the citizenship law it's about a
constitutional and existential crisis
and it crisis on the very fundamental
values on which this country was
established it doesn't look like this is
gonna fizzle out any time the government
is willing to well at least compromise
it's not back down on this
so the government is not backing down on
it and but neither are the protesters by
the sounds of it and it does look like a
big standoff it is it is very unsure
like how the government will react this
morning they're having like these buses
that have that were brought to the
center of the the city to bus in the
police and bus out the protesters so the
protesters are gonna continue as well as
the government is not willing to back
down as Viette all rights have been a
stressor they're from New Delhi thanks
for that